hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agent Carter episode 7 video we
only have one episode left and then the
next week after that agents of shield is
coming back so I'll try to explain what
the schedule is there hasn't been any
confirmation about season 2 but if they
say something before the finale airs
I'll be sure to include it in that video
next week so just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet
starting with top five moments number
five Doctor Faustus flashback the
character's name is dr. ivchenko but he
was holding that Doctor Faustus book so
everyone thinks he might be dr. Faustus
from the Marvel comics the showrunners
are kind of sidestepping that like
they're avoiding directly calling him
dr. Faustus but you can think of him
that way he has the same type of powers
that Doctor Faustus has in the comics
he's a Hydra character connected to the
Red Skull now because the antagonists
are Russian because leviathans Russian
on the TV show I think they're just
trying to separate this character from
the Marvel Comics it seems like based on
this flashback he's a good person he's a
psychiatrist trying to help soldiers
with PTSD or shell-shocked the look on
his face right here does not look like
he's trying to do something nice this is
like the look of villain has on their
face hopefully they'll explain how he
got tied up with Leviathan because when
we had the Black Widow flashback when we
had da DS flashback he was just sitting
in that chair living that's number four
agent Carter gets interrogated this is
like the fish shake WTF from the episode
just because we as the audience know
she's totally innocent and the SSR is
way behind of the story so we have to
wait for them to catch up with the
narrative and nothing is more
frustrating than watching your
protagonist waste time treating one of
their teammates like an
Peggy even said it you are wasting
precious time the team comes around they
start believing her but you know if you
have made a connection with the agent
Susa character and agent ops and these
other characters you feel this crushing
remorse of being a douchebag to Peggy
it's kinda hard to get excited about an
episode or a story or a scene when you
feel awful about yourself I feel like
that's one of the fundamental issues of
the show is that at times it can make
you feel like an imagine what
would happen if the Avengers were just
jerks to each other all the time it
would be such an unlikable franchise
that's that's why they have to have that
moment where they come together in the
episode like you have to have that wind
that team-based win and I feel like
because agent Carter's only eight
episodes it takes longer to get there
they have less time to spend on that
so you can still walk away after this
episode feeling kind of terrible about
yourself you just can let me know if you
agree but but do you feel like these
characters fighting with Peggy makes you
feel worse about yourself I feel like
it's really hard to get excited about
scenes like this widget which is why it
was like a big WTF for me moving on to
number three Peggy tells the truth
Jarvis's confession was a nice twist
he's like the pressure release valve in
the episode but he serves this really
important function is Peggy's sidekick
it's like he needs to embody the spirit
of adventure but be weak enough to make
Peggy seem like the real hero like when
they're together you're never confused
about who the sidekick is he's like the
Samwell Tarly - Peggy's Jon Snow and I
just love how the show plays around
Howard Starks absence the real reason I
think Dominic Cooper isn't around every
week is mostly because of availability
issues and cost and I kind of think the
people are more familiar with his
character so you'd start to
unconsciously think of it as the Howard
Stark show and Peggy would turn into a
supporting character regardless of the
show being called agent Carter sometimes
that can happen when you have characters
that are so popular they just overpower
the narrative it'd be like putting one
of the Avengers on the daredevil show
every week what are you gonna get more
excited about daredevil parkour or Iron
Man's new armor that being said it's a
really good problem to have when you
have characters that are too popular to
be in a story I mean it's like an
embarrassment of riches speaking of
which now that the SSR knows all about
Captain America's blood don't you just
wonder what's gonna happen to it I mean
right now it seems safe but we're in the
early stages of hydras infiltration it
just seems funny that they have all that
stark tech just lying around their lab
like it's no big deal moving on to
number two agent Dooley takes one for
the team
thanks to that whole hypnosis sequence
we finally get to see his family it's
always weird when you hear about
characters all the time but you never
see them on screen most of the time
that's actually used as a comedy device
like oh I can't believe my wife she
won't get off my case and you just you
just never see the wife when they were
walking through the lab and he picked
that vest up for the first time I was
actually expecting the camera to reveal
it as some sort of prototype Iron Man
armor I guess you could think of it that
way you could think of it as like arc
reactor prototype they never fully
explain with that power sources but it
does sound like the arc reactor as Tony
Stark described it in the first Iron Man
film he just says that it was an energy
source that his father could never get
to work properly and Jarvis went on and
on about how unstable all their tests
were
agent Dooley sacrificed did go a long
way towards humanizing his character
making him a little bit more likeable
he's been kind of a hard sell but I
guess you could understand where his
logic is flowing from I mean he's the
boss he has to go with the facts that
are presented to him it didn't seem like
the way he treated Peggy had anything to
do with her being a woman at least after
the first couple of episodes I wasn't
super connected to the character or so
so the death probably wasn't quite as
meaningful for me as say like one of the
other characters like agent Sousa if
he'd had died but I did like the way
they eulogized him with that dream
sequence I mean that was really nice
that was a fitting way to go out at
heart he's just a family man and my
number one moment
dotty and Doctor of chenko test Starks
nerve gas so they never gave it a real
name just item 17 but it works just like
the weapon in the Kingsmen movie I know
that's kind of meta because you could
think of Nick Fury as being the villain
in that movie because it's Sam Jackson I
won't spoil it if you haven't seen it
but there is a scene that's very similar
to this in the movie the place where
they filmed the episode the agent Carter
episode was actually the Los Angeles
theatre that was built in 1931 they took
a whole bunch of pictures from the
inside it's really cool it kind of
reminds me of an episode earlier this
season on Gotham that they shot inside
of a theatre but that shoots in New York
and agent Carter shoots in Los Angeles
so it's two different places this is
really funny thing going on like if you
ever saw inglourious basterds it's like
that nation's pride screening where the
theater burns down the idea of movies
inside movies they presented it in a
fairly straightforward way I don't think
that that real that they were watching
was intended to be anything crazy or
specific so let me know what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
here's my big question for you they said
Leviathan is coming the last episode is
called valediction which basically means
farewell so do you think that this is
going to be some sort of big general
attack or do you think that a big
villain is gonna step forward I know
they presented this dr. Faustus
character as the main villain but it
seemed like he got drummed into service
with Leviathan too so I'm wondering if
there's someone above him and if they're
doing their job and that the narrative
is really tightly constructed that we
probably met that villain already think
of it in terms of the flash the flash is
like a good benchmark for really
well-constructed narratives you meet all
the main characters all the ones that
are really important in the first
episode so you open and you close the
narrative with the same group of people
I already mentioned most of the Easter
eggs that I saw but if you guys saw any
others just right
in the comments I'd say my only thumbs
down in the episode has been the villain
character development I mean we note
Leviathan is the villain but we really
don't know more than they're just some
sort of vague Russian organization we
don't know if it's a person and we have
no idea what their real motives are I
mean yes they want stark tech and yes
they probably want to take over the
world but that feels like it's too vague
to be interesting world domination is
such an old plot device that it's hard
to take seriously so fingers crossed
that the twist and the finale makes the
conflict feel a lot more personal to
Peggy Jarvis Howard Stark it's just like
on the list of possible twists that you
can give an audience the villain turning
out to be a friend of yours is used a
little more rewarding than like a Hail
Mary Jo sex machinist situation where a
villain you've never seen before steps
in and says it was all me I did it all
like I said though no confirmation on
season 2 hopefully they'll make an
announcement before the finale next week
that's called valediction that's the
title the finale be sure to subscribe to
get my video for that the next week
after that shield comes back so we'll be
back to weekly shield videos pretty soon
lots of Inhumans and secret warriors
comic book stuff to talk about
in case you desert behind - there's a
new episode of arrow tonight Deathstroke
is coming back so be sure to watch it
I'll post my video after the episode
airs while you guys wait for all that
stuff to drop you can click here to
catch up on last night's bananas episode
of the flash and you can click here for
last week's agent Carter thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you tonight
you